je m'appelle Charles delfie je suis
président de la start-up constellation
technologies opération une start-up
incubée par 51 en Yvelines et nous
développons une constellation innovante
de satellite de télécommunication pour
permettre un accès à Internet au débit
fait-on latence là où les réseaux
technologies terrestres ne sont pas
disponibles à travers notre projet nous
portons deux grandes innovations une
première innovation qui s'appuie sur une
architecture multi orbite unique d'un
constellation de satellite des
communication et une deuxième orbite qui
consiste à réutiliser le spectre et
l'écosystème de la 5G développée pour
les ésotérisme de télécommunication
notre constellation s'appuie sur deux
couches de satellite une déployée en
moyenne orbite relativement distant de
la de la terre auprès de 8000 km
complété par une deuxième coule
satellite qui allait déployer à très
basse orbite après de 400 km aujourd'hui
nous avons réalisé tout un travail
d'ingénierie système qui nous a permis
de concevoir et d'optimiser terminé
cette constellation de satellites de
télécommunication au débit nous avons
également
développé des partenariats avec des
partenaires industriels qui seront
associés à notre start-up pour la
réalisation de ce projet nous prévoyons
dès la fin 2024 de pouvoir déployer des
premières capacités en orbite qui nous
permettront de tester des premières
briques technologiques de notre projet
aujourd'hui ce que l'on souhaite c'est
pouvoir offrir aux opérateurs des
communications du monde entier une
solution de connectivité par satellite
qui va compléter les services de
connectivité déjà offert aujourd'hui à
travers les réseaux cellulaire ou à
travers à travers la fièvre nous
travaillons aujourd'hui sur le
développement de l'ensemble des briques
technologiques qui nous permettront de
réaliser la démonstration de ce concept
très innovant à horizon 2025 2026 et
nous prévoyons par la suite un
déploiement complet de cette
constellation entre 2026 et 2029 une
fois de plus en partenariat avec les
opérateurs de télécommunication